We've had an incredible 24 hours in the United
States.
I want to start today with huge news out of
Minneapolis where the other three officers,
as they are known, involved in the death of
Jorge Floyd, have now been charged.
And the charges against Derek Schavan have
been upgraded from third degree murder to
second degree murder.
A lot to discuss.
So starting off with reminder, Derek Schavan
is the officer in the viral video that spurred
the national and even global protests.
The officer putting his knee to George Floyd's
neck for many minutes before George George
Floyd ultimately died.
The three officers visible in the video sort
of standing around as this happens, have now
been charged with aiding and abetting second
degree murder and aiding and abetting second
degree manslaughter, second degree murder,
and aiding and abetting second degree murder,
punishable by up to 40 years in prison.
Manslaughter, aiding and abetting manslaughter
punishable by up to 10 years in prison.
Now, let's talk about the Derek Schavan charges.
And this is there's a lot of detail here that's
important.
The original charges against Derek Schavan
were third degree murder and second degree
manslaughter.
The murder charge has now been upgraded to
second degree murder.
This is very important because second degree
murder carries with it.
Number one, a much more serious potential
sentence, but also, number two, potentially
a more difficult to prove case for the prosecution
in a sense.
Sort of maybe, except that the third degree
murder charges, when you look at the statute,
also may not have been the right ones for
the situation.
So, again, we've got to look at what the statutes
say.
In Minnesota, a third degree murder charge
is defined as, quote, whoever without intent
to effect the death of any person, meaning
without deliberately trying to kill someone
causes the death of another by perpetrating
an act eminently dangerous to others and evincing
a depraved mind not or evincing a depraved
mind and evincing a depraved mind without
regard for human life is guilty of murder
in the third degree.
So this is from the twenty nineteen Minnesota
statutes.
And what Schavan did would be very tough to
prove in a court of law as what's called a
depraved mind murder.
So you can make the case not that the charge
should be second degree versus third degree
based on the severity, so to speak, of what
Derek Schavan is accused of doing.
But because the third degree murder statute
includes this depraved mind component.
So instead, we have second degree murder here.
There are two types of second degree murder
in Minnesota statutes, intentional and unintentional.
If sharpens restraint of George Floyd caused
Floyd's death, he could be guilty of unintentional
second degree murder even if he was not trying
to kill George Floyd.
It would be very difficult to prove in a court
of law based on what we've seen, that Schavan
was trying to kill George Floyd.
It seems as though unintentional second degree
murder is the statute under which George Floyds
death would fall.
From the perspective of Derek Chauvin's actions,
now, there's one more analysis here about
this.
That's less about what you can prove, but
more about what Schavan is likely to plead
down to.
So let me kind of frame this up for you in
a different way.
If this goes to trial, I think it's going
to be tough, but not impossible to get a guilty
verdict against Derek Schavan.
That has nothing to do with my opinion about
what went down.
It is merely my understanding of how these
trials often work and what the law is.
So bear with me here.
We have two autopsies that were done of George
Floyd so far that that I've read in one of
those autopsies.
The cause of death is not alone.
The actions of Derek Schavan, the cause of
death says it was not asphyxiation by Derek
Schavan and it was the restraint used by Derek
Schavan, combined with preexisting medical
conditions and possible intoxication.
Now, you and I may think that that's B.S.
And indeed, there's a second autopsy which
says something very different, which says
that the death was indeed caused by asphyxiation
as a result of Derek Chauvin's actions.
But my point is, if this goes to trial, a
good defense attorney, which Derek Schavan
will certainly have, is very much able to
introduce.
Reasonable doubt about whether Chauvin's actions
definitely are the cause of George Floyds
death by focusing on the one autopsy that
says, you know, there were preexisting medical
conditions that were a factor, possible intoxication
and restraint.
You bring in some medical examiners that they'll
find and say, Doctor, whoever given this autopsy,
is it possible that absent George Floyds medical
conditions and possible intoxication, that
he could have survived the way that he was
restrained by Derek Schavan?
Yes, counsel, that's possible.
So you and I both understand that this is
apparently B.S., but you would then have a
fight, a legal fight where the defense is
introducing doubt and the prosecution is saying,
well, we have a different autopsy.
This OP Topsy does say that George Floyd was
asphyxiated by Derek Schavan.
But it becomes a fight.
And remember, you only need reasonable doubt
to acquit.
The standard of evidence in a civil trial
may well be a preponderance of evidence.
Does it seem like 51 percent of the evidence
points to Derek Chauvin's responsibility?
In a criminal trial, you need only introduce
reasonable doubt.
So this gets me back to the reason for moving
from third degree murder to second degree
murder.
Is the idea that you go to a second degree
murder charge because it carries a higher
penalty so that you increase the desire from
Derek Schavan to plead to something smaller
to avoid a trial altogether, which may or
may not go well for the prosecution.
That's another possibility as to why you would
have seen an elevated charge from third degree
murder to second degree murder.
Needless to say, it is correct to elevate
the charge to second degree murder based on
our reading of the Minnesota statutes.
And it is a good thing that the other officers
have been charged and all were brought in
yesterday.
This is going to be this is going to be a
very long thing in.
By every indication, this will not be resolved
for far longer than the current protests are
likely to go.
So we've got to really buckle in and realize
that this is going to be a long process.
Speedy trial.
OK, it is still going to be a long and protracted
process.